Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
Sapete riconoscere cos'è questo oggetto?
È un carro a vapore,
che è universalmente considerato
come la prima automobile della storia.
Era un veicolo a tre ruote,
la cui ruota anteriore
era motrice e sterzante.
Era un veicolo molto
difficile da manovrare:
pesava quattro o cinque tonnellate,
e poteva raggiungere una velocità massima
di soli 16 chilometri all'ora.
L'inventore, Cugnot, nonostante il peso
trascurò un aspetto importante,
per questo veicolo:
trascurò il fatto di dotarlo
di un sistema frenante.
Infatti, il primo veicolo
fece una brutta fine:
finì contro un muro.
(Risate)
Mai fermarsi al primo tentativo.
Evidentemente, Cugnot fece
così tanta fatica, per farlo muovere,
che non volle nulla
che lo potesse fermare.
È il primo esempio
di veicolo "automobile",
nel senso letterale del termine:
cioè che si muove da sé
senza il bisogno
di energia animale o eolica.
Ed era un veicolo
relativamente libero di muoversi,
perché non era vincolato da rotaie.
Questo è un primo aspetto importante
della nostra mobilità: la libertà.
Ma un altro veicolo, secondo me,
che segna molto quello che è
il nostro modello di mobilità
è la Ford Modello T,
che venne prodotta dal 1908 in America
ed è il primo esempio
di vettura prodotta in serie.
Infatti, dal 1913 questo veicolo
venne prodotto con la catena di montaggio,
che certo ebbe un forte influsso
sullo sviluppo della società
del XX secolo.
Ma fu il primo esempio
di veicolo accessibile a tutti,
e che rese tutti
molto più liberi e indipendenti.
Ne vennero prodotti ben 15 milioni
di esemplari in 19 anni:
un numero enorme.
E in quel periodo, in America,
circa metà del parco macchine
era costituito da una Ford Modello T.
Ovviamente, con questo modello
di diffusione di massa degli autoveicoli,
anche delle regole del traffico
si svilupparono lentamente;
e spesso, le regole
si svilupparono prima delle leggi.
Attualmente, queste regole
hanno ancora problemi
a essere uniformate su scala globale.
Pensiamo, semplicemente,
alla semplice regola
della guida a sinistra,
o della guida a destra.
Se noi dobbiamo passare
dal continente a Macao, ad esempio,
dobbiamo fare un autentico
gioco di prestigio:
dobbiamo passare per il Ponte Lotus,
e quindi passare
per rampe contorte, intricate,
che ci permettano di passare
dalla guida a sinistra
alla guida a destra.
Ovviamente, questo modello di mobilità
ha reso tutti molto più liberi
e indipendenti,
ha dato a tutti la possibilità di essere
dove si vuole, quando si vuole.
Ma se noi andiamo a vedere
la velocità media del traffico
di 100 anni fa,
in confronto a oggi,
notiamo che, insomma, la situazione
non sembra cambiata molto.
(Ride)
Inoltre c'è anche il problema dello spazio
che bisogna dedicare
a tutti questi veicoli,
perché ovviamente questa cosa
richiede moltissimo investimento
anche a livello di spazi.
Oltretutto, questi veicoli,
la maggior parte del tempo,
rimangono fermi;
e quindi potrebbe anche essere vista
come un'enorme quantità
di capitali e risorse inutilizzate.
Quello che si pensa di poter fare,
per risolvere il problema del traffico,
è quello di utilizzare
l'interconnessione dei veicoli,
e le funzionalità di guida autonoma,
per poter aumentare
la velocità media del traffico.
È molto importante -
ad esempio, l'idea
che sta alla base di questo
è la possibilità di far andare i veicoli
più o meno alla stessa velocità,
e alla stessa distanza reciproca.
In questo modo, la stessa strada
può permettere di far passare
un maggior flusso di traffico
rispetto alla situazione
dove tanti veicoli procedono
in modo casuale,
cambiando corsia in continuazione
e non mantenendo la distanza corretta
rispetto al veicolo che precede.
In questo esempio, voglio mostrare
una semplice simulazione del traffico,
in cui la strada non è altro
che un semplice anello circolare.
Inizialmente, i veicoli procedono
più o meno tutti alla stessa velocità,
utilizzando l'interconnessione
e scambiandosi informazioni.
Improvvisamente,
questa funzionalità viene a mancare:
e cosa succede?
Che i veicoli cominciano
a cambiare corsia in modo casuale,
e a non mantenere la distanza corretta
rispetto ai veicoli che precedono.
Si vede che la velocità,
il flusso del traffico,
diminuisce enormemente;
e addirittura i veicoli si fermano,
o procedono nel modo cosiddetto "a bruco".
Una cosa importante, anche, da ricordare,
è che la guida autonoma
potrebbe anche permettere
di avere dei vantaggi
a livello di traffico
semplicemente per il fatto
che dei modelli di mobilità
molto più evoluti potrebbero svilupparsi,
e quindi il numero
di veicoli necessari sarebbe minore,
con ovvi benefici, anche,
dal punto di vista dell'ambiente.
Ma la cosa più interessante, secondo me,
riguardo alla guida autonoma
è che, specie nelle grandi città,
si possa chiamare la propria auto
con un telefonino,
e permettere che questa
ti porti al lavoro,
mentre io posso far altro,
ovviamente è un'opportunità interessante
che potrebbe permettere di risparmiare
molto tempo della nostra vita,
e di guadagnare molto tempo
della nostra vita.
Una cosa importante da dire,
per quanto riguarda i nuovi modelli
di mobilità che ho accennato:
ovviamente, poter chiamare
la propria macchina con un telefonino
permetterebbe a più utenti di condividere,
anche, il valore dell'automobile.
Quindi non sarebbe più necessario
che molti utenti siano
proprietari dell'automobile,
ma il valore dell'automobile
potrebbe essere condiviso.
Quindi si parla di robotaxi,
che saranno delle automobili
con della strumentazione molto più evoluta
di quella dei veicoli
attualmente circolanti,
pur rimanendo sostenibili
a livello economico
e permettendo comunque
uno sviluppo economico
e nuove opportunità di sviluppo economico.
Però, prima di procedere
bisogna dire due parole
su quella che è la complessità,
per arrivare a questi modelli
evoluti di guida autonoma.
Attualmente, le norme considerano
cinque livelli di guida autonoma.
È importante considerare che,
tra il livello due e il livello tre,
c'è un passaggio fondamentale:
mentre a livello due la guida autonoma
deve essere monitorata dal guidatore,
al livello tre la guida autonoma
può essere monitorata
dal sistema di controllo stesso.
In questo caso, il guidatore
può veramente pensare di far altro.
Teniamo presente
che tutt'oggi, in commercio,
ci sono veicoli che arrivano
al livello due,
o comunque al livello tre
ma con forti limitazioni,
tipo di velocità;
o possono avere
una funzionalità di tipo tre
solo in autostrada.
Ovviamente, il livello più evoluto,
più interessante, è il livello cinque,
in cui il volante potrebbe
addirittura scomparire,
e chiamare la propria auto
con il telefonino
sarebbe effettivamente
qualcosa di possibile.
Però bisogna dire anche due parole
su quella che è
la complessità del software,
per arrivare al livello cinque.
Stime dicono che si passerebbe
dall'attuale 100 milioni
di righe di codice, per un livello due,
a circa due miliardi.
Il che vuol dire che per poter garantire,
con il 95 percento di confidenza,
la sicurezza degli autoveicoli,
cioè pari ai livelli attuali,
sarebbero necessari circa
otto miliardi di chilometri,
ovvero 100 veicoli che girano
per 24 ore al giorno per 220 anni.
Fortunatamente, ci sono tecniche
che permettono di accelerare
queste tempistiche:
una è quella dell'utilizzo del simulatore.
Il simulatore, in ambiente
controllato e sicuro
permette di sviluppare molto più in fretta
funzionalità di guida autonoma;
piste specifiche dove,
anche qua in sicurezza,
si possono sviluppare
funzionalità di guida autonoma;
oppure veicoli prototipo particolari.
Io mi occupo in particolare
di veicoli prototipo di questo tipo,
cioè "by wire",
in cui la connessione
tra i comandi pilota e le ruote
viene a mancare:
è solo elettronica, diciamo così.
E ovviamente, su questi veicoli
si studia la possibilità
di mantenerli sicuri
anche nel caso, diciamo così,
fortuito e improbabile
in cui qualcosa si possa rompere
in questa macchina.
Quindi, questi veicoli
sono in grado di riportarmi a casa;
o al limite, nei casi peggiori,
di accostare in modo sicuro.
Un altro aspetto importante,
che indica le tempistiche di arrivo
della guida autonoma
sulle strade di tutti i giorni,
sono, ovviamente,
anche i problemi etici legali.
Innanzitutto, bisogna garantire
che il livello di rischio sia lo stesso
dell'attuale guida manuale.
E in particolare, anche,
che il livello di rischio
sia uguale per tutte
le categorie di utenti,
non solo per i passeggeri:
quindi per i pedoni, per i ciclisti
e per gli altri utenti della strada.
Per fare questo si stanno
definendo delle metriche;
ma anche questo richiede tempo.
Un altro aspetto fondamentale è, invece,
anche quello delle responsabilità.
Le responsabilità
dovranno essere ridistribuite
tra utenti, costruttori e infrastruttura;
e ovviamente, in molti casi,
queste tre categorie faranno fatica
a riconoscere dei nuovi obblighi.
Tendiamo a pensare che,
con un livello cinque,
tutta la responsabilità è in mano
al costruttore dell'autoveicolo.
Questo non è vero,
perché comunque anche l'utente
manterrà delle responsabilità
che dovranno essere riconosciute.
Quindi, quello che si sta facendo adesso
è di definire delle leggi
prima che certe funzionalità
arrivino su strada.
E la legge deve definire esattamente
chi è responsabile e di che cosa.
Un altro aspetto importante
è quello dei dilemmi.
Ci saranno situazioni,
vicino all'incidente stradale,
in cui il veicolo dovrà decidere
chi salvare e chi sacrificare.
In queste condizioni,
un programma implementato nel veicolo
dovrà dare dei pesi,
dovrà fare delle scelte etiche
per definire quanto può valere
la vita di un bambino
rispetto a quella di un anziano,
rispetto a quella di una donna incinta,
rispetto a quella di un medico,
di una persona che segue
le regole del traffico
rispetto a uno che non le segue.
Fortunatamente, un vantaggio
è quello che queste scelte etiche
verranno fatte in modo obiettivo,
e non lasciate all'istinto del guidatore.
Però, allo stesso tempo,
definire questi pesi,
e definire delle regole
che siano accettate da tutti
non è altrettanto facile.
Detto ciò, vorrei dire
che ovviamente ci vorrà molto tempo
prima che la guida autonoma arrivi -
soprattutto nei livelli più avanzati -
sulle strade di tutti i giorni.
E sicuramente, la guida autonoma
darà dei vantaggi
dal punto di vista
dell'economia, dell'ambiente,
della gestione della nostra vita.
Però, bisogna anche riconoscere
che alcuni dei vantaggi che abbiamo
con il nostro modello di mobilità
attualmente stanno pian piano scomparendo.
E quindi, il nostro modello
dovrebbe naturalmente evolvere
per permettere di mantenere
questi vantaggi.
(Applausi)